[Musique]
alors l'objectif de la séance c'est la
poursuite du carnet d'automne que vous
avez engagé pendant les vacances sauf
que là on va rajouter une contrainte qui
est le thème d'aujourd'hui qui est le
silence c'est vraiment une thématique
est compliqué comme à traiter puisque
dans nos cours en essais comme de
valoriser justement la parole échange on
essaye d'avoir quand même quelque chose
de sonore mais on est dans un nouvel
enjeu l'enjeu c'est aussi pour vous en
gros questionner aussi l'important
justement du du silence dans aussi un
processus créatif
[Musique]
donc bienvenue au parc de la branche
choix c'est donc ce lieu est à vraiment
à deux pas de
de notre lycée donc allé là vous avez
quartier libre vous pouvez partir
partent
[Musique]
ma chercher quelque chose d'intéressant
à dessiner quelque chose que les gens ne
voient pas forcément au quotidien mais
eh bien je vois ces plantes où je me
suis dit ça peut être un joli plan a
dessiné donc
d'habitude je ne dessine pas par terre
et je me dis bah tiens pourquoi pas
essayer avec ce silence je me fais un
peu de musique dans ma tête comme ça ça
sachant peut-être pas que je ne sache
pas content pour moi mais c'est vrai que
un long silence bien besoin comme ça
c'est vrai qu'il a une fois ça fait du
bien
plus classe
après j'aime bien c'est calme j'aime
beaucoup c'est fait de silence parce
qu'on peut vraiment se concentrer
pas très bon signe vraiment dans la
nature même du bruit et cetera et il
n'entend pas beaucoup du coup enfin les
voitures mais l'entrée très peu et c'est
vachement bien
[Musique]
le silence est vraiment très reposant
quand on est si c'est ça aide beaucoup
plus à réfléchir à observer mieux c'est
vraiment très très enrichissant de faire
ça ici
moi je suis toujours habitués à
travailler avec un petit fond sonore et
bages des musiques où je sais vous allez
forcément bas comme n'y a pas de bruit
ouais c'est perturbant moi ça me faire
sur beaucoup mais après c'est reposant
pour le coup je vais une plante qui est
juste là mais légèrement altérée avec de
quoi un peu plus saturé pour un peu plus
officiel le côté auteuil automnale tout
ça voilà
et puis pour l'expérience c'est super
intéressant par un pot silence parce que
comme toujours de la classe on travaille
ensemble vous même quand on est tout
seul en classe ne pas que sa musique son
casque on pas le prof donc on n'est
jamais vraiment tous âges avaient
vraiment dans sa tête
du coup la fadeur bas c'est vraiment pas
de vivre plus dans le moment est de 120
sur des détails près je pense qu'il ya
plein de choses à essayer d'obtenir par
rapport au silence donc c'est disais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment d'insister sur le fait que
c'est une ressource le silence pour
inciter sur une concentration sur un
état d'esprit en mode dirt l'action se
tourne aussi vers les autres clans n'est
justement dans l'appropriation justement
d'un site analysé un site aussi être
capable de par le dessin fait être
capable justement d'en extraire
quasiment plein d'éléments
[Musique]
or là il ya une série que voilà une
minutieuse on est toujours dans quelle
technique d'implant donc beaucoup
s'aggraverait que là qu'en couleurs les
neuf pros marque un stylo bic le tout
mélangé tout mélanger donc là on est
vraiment des techniques mixtes en fait
des choses assez surprenante
tu des cours on a vraiment là une
approche expérimentale quoi
[Musique]